CORRUPT THEY REALLY ARE AND
♪ ALL RIGHT, BREAKING RIGHT
NOW, TRUTH AND TRANSPARENCY
ARE UNDER ASSAULT IN OUR
COUNTRY.
DEMOCRATS, THE LIBERAL
MEDIA.
THEORIES ABOUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP WITH IMPUNITY.
NOW IT HAS NOW REACHED THE
POINT WHERE THEY WANT TO
HURT THE PRESIDENT SO BADLY
THAT THEY ARE NOW TURNING ON
WE, THE PEOPLE, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND THEY REFUSE TO
PURSUE WHAT IS TRUTH.
WITH ALL THE EVIDENCE THAT
THEY CAN MUSTER.
NOW IN THEIR PANIC, THEY ARE
TRYING TO UTTERLY DESTROY
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE EXPOSING
HERE IS WHY.
IT HAS BEEN A YEAR OF HELL
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
THE MEDIA HAS BEEN LYING THE
WHOLE TIME.
THEY HAVE BEEN PUSHING
PROPAGANDA, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ABOUT TRUMP/RUSSIA
COLLUSION EVEN THOUGH
EVIDENCE DOES NOT EXIST.
IT'S A FABRICATION.
IT'S CONSTRUCTED IN THEIR
LIBERAL MEDIA ECHO CHAMBER
AND THEN FALSELY REPEATED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THEY MAY EVEN BELIEVE THEIR
OWN LIES.
RANKING DEMOCRATS AND
NATIONAL SECURITY OFFICIALS
THEM.
>> THE ALLEGATION OF THAT
THE RUSSIANS AND HACKING AND
DUMPING OF DOCUMENTS IN THE
ELECTION HAD ESSENTIALLY
RELATIONSHIPS WITH TRUMP
THAT THERE IS PROOF YOU
COULD TAKE TO A JURY.
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH THIS
CONCLUSION THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS REACHED THAT
>> YOU KNOW, WE HAVEN'T SEEN
ANY OF THAT WHATSOEVER,
GEORGE.
WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING AND
EVERYTHING THEY POSSIBLY
HAVE.
THAT HAS NOT LED TO THAT.
>> THE LAST TIME WE SPOKE,
SENATOR, I ASKED YOU IF HAD
YOU ACTUALLY SEEN EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION BETWEEN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THE
RUSSIANS AND YOU SAID TO ME
AND I'M QUOTING YOU NOW, YOU
WE SPOKE LAST?
>> WELL, NOT -- NO, IT
HASN'T.
>> JUST TO BE CLEAR, THERE
HAS BEEN NO ACTUAL EVIDENCE
YET?
>> NO, IT HAS NOT BEEN.
>> AT THE TIME I LEFT, I DID
NOT HAVE -- SEE ANY SMOKING
GUN CERTITUDE OF EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
THEY HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON
PERPETUATING SOMETHING THEY
KNOW IS A LIE.
AMERICAN SCANDAL THAT MAKES
WATERGATE, THE PENTAGON
PAPERS, LOOK LIKE MINOR
INFRACTIONS.
NOW, FOX NEWS IS REPORTING
TONIGHT THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS, IN FACT, REVIEWED THE
FOUR PAGE CLASSIFIED MEMO
ETHICS POSES MASSIVE AND
SEVERE FISA ABUSES AGAINST
MEMBERS OF HIS CAMPAIGN AND
THEN HIS INCOMING CABINET.
SOURCES ARE TELLING US THE
AS CAN YOU IMAGINE, AFTER A
BREATHLESSLY DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN POSSIBLY
DO TO DISCREDIT AND STOP THE
MEMO FROM BEING RELEASED.
WHAT ARE THEY SO AFRAID OF?
CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF?
HE WENT RUNNING TO ALL HIS
LIBERAL ALLIES IN THE MEDIA
LIKE PAUL REVERE CLAIMING
THAT THE MEMO SENT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE HAD BEEN, QUOTE:
SECRETLY ALTERED AND, QUOTE,
MATERIAL CHANGES WERE MADE.
NOW, IN SCHIFF'S TWISTED
MIND, THIS MEANS THAT THE
MEMO WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO BE
RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC
BECAUSE HOUSE RULES WERE
VIOLATED.
AND THE MEDIA GOES INTO FULL
HYPER VENTILATION MODE AND
THEY WERE ECSTATIC AND THEY
WERE ALL WRONG.
FIRST, JUST TAKE A LOOK AT
FEELING THE HEAT OF THOSE
CRITICISMS AND ACCORDING TO
ADAM SCHIFF GOING TO THE
POINT OF MAKING MATERIAL
CHANGES IN THE MEMO.
PARADE OF DEPOSIT PRIX CHERRY OT
PARADE OF DEPOSIT PRIX CHERRY OP
PARADE OF DEPOSIT PRIX CHERRY OO
PARADE OF DEPOSIT PRIX CHERRY OF
THAT SUNDAE.
>> NOW HAVE YOU DEVIN NUNES
WHO MADE A FOOL OF HIMSELF
HE WAS A COURIER FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
NOW HE IS COMING FORWARD AND
AS YOU SAID, THEY HAVE
COOKED -- THEY HAVE COOKED
FACTS IN A MEMO.
>> THAT'S WHAT ADAM SCHIFF
SAYS.
>> NOT ONLY THAT IT'S WHAT
DEVIN NUNES' PEOPLE SAY.
HE EITHER ALTERED IT A
LITTLE OR ALTERED IT A LOT
WHICH IS WHAT ADAM SCHIFF'S
PEOPLE SAY TO WATER IT DOWN
BEFORE SENDING IT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
EITHER WAY, THEY ALTERED IT.
ISN'T THERE PROTOCOL?
>> SEE THE ECHO CHAMBER?
YOU HAVE THE LIBERAL
CONGRESSMAN AND THE LIBERAL
MEDIA AND THEY ECHO EACH
OTHER.
WOW, BIG SURPRISE AND THEY
ARE WRONG.
SCHIFF IS LYING.
OUR OWN CATHERINE HERRIDGE
REPORTING TONIGHT THAT EDITS
MADE TO THE MEMO WERE FOR A
GRAMMAR AND B CLARITY AND
ADDITIONAL EDITS THE ONES
THAT WERE DONE WERE
AND AT THE REQUEST OF
DEMOCRATS, MEANING PEOPLE
LIKE ADAM SCHIFF ON THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
NOW, THIS PART IS VERY KEY
AND I HOPE ADAM SCHIFF IS
LISTENING, BECAUSE HE
APPARENTLY WAS RUSHING TO AN
MSNBC INTERVIEW WHICH THE
MEMO WAS BEING UPDATED.
ALL OF THE EDITS WERE MADE
BEFORE THE MEMO WAS SENT TO
THE WHITE HOUSE FOR REVIEW
AND NOT AFTER LIKE SCHIFF IS
DISTRACTION FASHION NANCY
PELOSI, CHUCK SCHUMER, THEY
ARE ALL DOING THEIR BEST TO
DISPARAGE THE MEMO AND
ATTACKING HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN DEVIN
NUNES.
NOTICE THEY ALL SOUND ALIKE.
ONE BIG LYING ECHO CHAMBER.
IT'S AMAZING.
PROPAGANDA.
>> THE RELEASE OF THIS MEMO
IS REALLY REMINISCENT OF THE
DARKEST DAYS OF THE MCCARTHY
ERA WITH CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION.
IT ENDANGERS METHODS AND
SOURCES OF THE INTELLIGENCE
REPUBLICANS DECLARED WAR
TODAY ON OUR NATIONAL
ALLEGATIONS IN THE MEMO ARE
SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
>> IF HE WERE TO RELEASE
BE ENDANGERING OUR COUNTRY,
BUT HE WOULD ALSO BE
VIOLATING THE RULES OF THE
CONGRESS OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> WE DON'T CHERRY PICK
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AND
PUBLISH IT TO GIVE THE
PRESIDENT'S HIDE.
>> THE LIBERAL MEDIA IS
FOLLOWING THEIR COMMANDS
FROM THEIR DEMOCRATIC ALLIES
BECAUSE THEY ARE ONE BIG
GROUP TOGETHER AND ALL THEY
HAVE IN THE MEDIA IS AN
EXTENSION OF WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS WANT.
THEY ARE ALSO TRYING TO SLAM
THE MEMO.
WHY ARE THEY SO AFRAID OF
>> HE AND HIS REPUBLICAN
ALLIES ARE PREPARING A
FRONTAL ASSAULT ON THIS
COUNTRY'S LAW ENFORCEMENT
INSTITUTIONS.
THE TRUMP ATTACK HINGES ON A
MEMO THAT TRUMP'S REPUBLICAN
MINIONS ON THE HOUSE
>> JOHN KELLY SAYS HE WANTS
EVERYTHING OUT, EVEN IF THE
REPUBLICANS MAY GET THEIR
MEMO RELEASED TODAY, BUT IT
WILL NOT BE THE LAST SHOE TO
DROP.
>> THIS MEMO IS A PACK OF
LIES AND YET WE ARE STILL
RIGHT NOW ON TRACK TO HAVE
IT RELEASED.
>> THIS IS A TIPPING POINT
FOR OUR DEMOCRACY.
COULD HAUNT THIS WHITE HOUSE
THAT WILL HAUNT THIS COUNTRY
IF WE DON'T FIX WHAT HAS
HAPPENED WHICH I WILL BE
EXPLAINING.
EVEN DISGRACED FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY, WELL,
IS HE TRYING TO GET IN ON
THE ACTION.
AND TONIGHT COMEY TWEETED
BUT TAKE HEART, AMERICAN
HISTORY SHOWS THAT IN THE
LONG RUN WEASELS AND LIARS
NEVER HOLD THE FIELD SO LONG
AS GOOD PEOPLE STAND UP.
NOT A LOT OF SCHOOLS OR
STREETS ARE NAMED AFTER JOE
BY THE WAY, JIM, JUST A
REMINDER, YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
AND JIM COMEY NEEDS TO BE
PUT UNDER OATH.
HE NEEDS TO BE QUESTIONED.
CLINTON MONTHS BEFORE YOU
DID THE INVESTIGATION,
BEFORE IT EVER TOOK PLACE.
AND, JIM, WHAT DO YOU KNOW
ABOUT TRUMP-HATING FBI
AGENTS PETER STRZOK AND LISA
PAGE AND JAMES COMEY, WHAT
DO YOU KNOW ABOUT ANDREW
MCCABE WAITING THREE WEEKS
TO ALERT CONGRESS ABOUT THE
EMAILS THAT HAVE BEEN FOUND
ON ANTHONY WEINER'S LAPTOP.
AND, BY THE WAY, WHAT DID
YOU KNOW AND WHEN DID YOU
DID YOU KNOW IT WAS
FIRESTONE, JIM?
DID
PHD
PHONY,JIM?
DID YOU KNOW IT WAS
PRESENTED TO A FISA COURT?
DID YOU WANT TO PAY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE THE
FORMER BRITISH SPY THAT PUT
IT TOGETHER WITH RUSSIAN
SOURCES THAT HE LIKELY PAID?
SO, JIM, LET'S CUT THE
TODAY HAPPENED ON YOUR
WATCH.
AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, I
DON'T SEE ANY STREETS IN THE
FUTURE BEING NAMED AFTER
JAMES COMEY.
BUT, IF I WAS YOU, JIM, I
WOULD BE SAVING THESE
COMMENTS FOR YOUR LAWYERS.
NOW, BACK TO THE MEMO THAT
WE HEAR WILL BE RELEASED
TOMORROW.
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
THE SMEM
THE MMEM
THE MEMM
THE MEMO IS ONLY 10 TO 15%
OF INFORMATION THAT WILL BE
TONIGHT JOHN SOLOMON OF THE
HILL IS REPORTING
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
THAT WE HAVE BEEN
HIGHLIGHTING AND SPECIAL
COUNSEL, ROBERT MUELLER'S
PROBE WERE BASED ON, QUOTE:
FLAWED OR POLITICALLY
TAINTED EVIDENCE CONNECTED
TO PARTISANS LOYAL TO
HILLARY CLINTON.
NOW, THAT WOULD MEAN THE
ENTIRE THING WAS BASED ON
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
LIES.
AND IF THE MEDIA HAD ANY
ETHICAL STANDARDS LEFT.
AND IF THEY REALLY CARED
ABOUT TRUTH.
IF THEY CARED ABOUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, IF THEY
PEOPLE, THAT THE MEMO BE
RELEASED.
NOW, LET'S PUT THIS IN A
LITTLE HISTORICAL CONTEXT
HERE.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU A COUPLE
OF EXAMPLES.
FROM THE HEADQUARTERS OF THE
OTHER PARTY IN A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION AND
THEN YOU LIE AND COVER IT
UP.
A PRESIDENT WAS REMOVED FROM
OFFICE AND HAD TO RESIGN
OVER THAT HERE'S HOW THE
MEDIA COVERED WATERGATE.
THEN THEY WERE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
NOT AS PARTISAN AS TODAY.
>> AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW BY
NOW, SEVEN PERSONS WERE
INDICTED TODAY FOR TRYING TO
COVER UP THE WATERGATE
SCANDALS OVERSHADOWING WHAT
HAPPENS TO THOSE SEVEN MEN
IS THE MORE IMPORTANT
QUESTION WHAT DOES TODAY'S
DEVELOPMENT MEAN FOR RICHARD
NIXON?
NOW OVER?
OR ONLY BEGINNING?
MOST SERIOUS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL PUT UP
A GREAT DEAL EVEN WHEN THE
DEMANDS ON THEM ARE
OUTRAGEOUS AS THEY OFTEN
ARE.
BUT THEY WILL NOT PUT UP
WITH ANYONE WHO CLAIMS TO BE
OR TRIES TO BE ABOVE THE
LAW.
IT SEEMS TO BE KNOWN
INSTINCTIVELY THAT IF ANYONE
ACQUIRES THAT PRIVILEGE, IT
WILL BE THE END OF THIS
THE LAW?
DO WE HAVE A DUAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM?
DO WE HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE SNRAW COMPARE THAT
COVERAGE TO WHAT WE SHOWED
YOU EARLIER HOW THE MEDIA IS
TRYING TO ALIGN RIDICULE A
MEMO, DETAILING A MAJOR FISA
ABUSE AGAINST AN OPPOSITION
PARTY DURING A CAMPAIGN.
THIS SCANDAL IN THE END WILL
MAKE WATERGATE LOOK LIKE A
PARKING TICKET.
SHOCKS THE CONSCIOUS.
YET THE MEDIA DOESN'T WANT
YOU TO SEE IT AND SEEMINGLY
DOESN'T CARE AS THEY DO THE
BIDDING FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY LIKE THEY HAVE DONE
FOR A YEAR, PUSHING A FALSE
TRUMP-RUSSIA NARRATIVE THAT
HAS NO EVIDENCE.
NOW THE MEDIA IS NOW
ACTIVELY WORKING AND IN
CONCERT WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THEY ARE WORKING TO PREVENT
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
FROM SEEING WHAT'S IN THE
MEMO.
AND ALL OF THIS PROVES IS
THAT THE NEWS MEDIA, THEY
DON'T SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
CIVIL LIBERTIES.
WE DO HAVE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS, THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT ON UNREASONABLE
SEARCH AND SEIZURE, AND THE
MEDIA HAVE JUST BECOME
SHRILLS AND HACKS FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARE ONLY FOCUSED ON
UNDERMINING AND DESTROYING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHATEVER THEY CAN POSSIBLY
FIND OR DO OR MAKE UP.
HERE IS ANOTHER HISTORICAL
COMPARISON.
REMEMBER THE PENTAGON
PAPERS?
THAT EXPOSED HOW THE
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT,
TO THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
COUNTRY'S INVOLVEMENT IN
AND "THE WASHINGTON POST" AT
THE TIME, THEY FOUGHT ALL
PUBLISH THOSE CLASSIFIED
GUESS WHAT?
THE TRUTH WAS EXPOSED.
NOW THE MEDIA IS DOING THE
EXACT OPPOSITE.
THEY WANT THE MEMO KEPT
SECRET, WHICH IS PATHETIC.
THEY ARE DOING A GREAT
DISSERVICE TO YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
INSTEAD, PUSHING FOR TRUTH.
THEY ARE NOW TRYING TO
ATTACK ANYBODY THAT IS
TRYING TO EXPOSE THE BIGGEST
CASE OF ABUSE OF POWER WE
HAVE EVER SEEN IN OUR
LIFETIME.
AND PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING
TO BE TRANSPARENT AND LET
YOU SEE THE TRUTH ARE UNDER
ATTACK BY THE PRESS AND THE
LEFT THAT HAS NOW ALIGNED
THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE ONE IN UNISON NOW.
THERE IS NO SEPARATION
BETWEEN LEFT WING LIBERAL
POLITICIANS AND YOUR MEDIA.
NO LINE OF SEPARATION.
THE MEDIA IS A BUNCH OF
WILLING ACCOMPLICES AND
BASICALLY PROPAGANDISTS.
ENTIRE YEAR.
HERE'S WHAT THEY WON'T TELL
YOU.
THIS IS WHAT THIS ALL COMES
DOWN TO.
THE SCANDAL STARTS WITH
HILLARY CLINTON.
THEY DON'T CARE IF SHE
RIGGED DONNA BRAZILE, HEAD
OF THE DNC, RIGGED A PRIMARY
AGAINST BERNIE SANDERS.
IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP DID
THAT AND IN THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY.
LISA PAGE ANDREW MCCAIN AND
PROBABLY LORETTA LYNCH THEY
PUT THE FIX IN PROTECTING
HILLARY CLINTON WITH AN
EXONERATION BEFORE AN
INVESTIGATION EVEN THOUGH WE
KNOW SHE MISHANDLE AND
DESTROYED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND BROKE THE
LAW.
FROM THERE, CLINTON TOOK
THAT IDEA OF RIGGING
PRIMARIES AND THEN TRIED TO
APPLY IT TO THE GENERAL
ELECTION.
HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN
TURNED OUT TO BE UNVERIFIED,
TOTALLY FALSE, A DOSSIER
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES TO
INFLUENCE AND LIE TO YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEN, THIS IS WHERE IT GETS
INTERESTING.
THIN THAT CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DOSSIER WAS THEN
TAKEN BY SENIOR OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION FBI OFFICIALS
NOT RANK AND FILE, WE LOVE
THEM.
AND USED IN PARTENNED AND
THIS IS WHAT WE WILL LEARN
TOMORROW, TO OBTAIN A FISA
WARRANT TO SPY ON MEMBERS OF
THE OPPOSITION PARTY, THE
POLITICIZED AND WEAPONIZED
AMERICA'S POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE TO SPY ON AN
OPPOSITION CAMPAIGN DURING
AN ELECTION YEAR AND
SHREDDING THE CONSTITUTION
IN THE PROCESS.
HOW DO YOU PEOPLE IN THE